[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lastly the third moment of the truth and
of enlightenment is the relation of the
individual being to absolute being is
the relation between the first two
moments in sight qua procure insight of
what is identical or unrestricted also
goes beyond what is not identical that
is beyond finite reality or beyond
itself as mere other nests
for the beyond of this other nests it
has the void to which therefore it
relates the sensuous reality in the
determination of this relation both of
the sides do not enter as content for
one of them is the void and it is only
through the other the sensuous reality
that a content is present but the form
of the relation to the determination of
which the side of the in itself
contributes can be a matter of choice
for the form is something intrinsically
negative and therefore self opposed
being as well as nothing the in itself
as well as its opposite or what is the
same thing the relation of the actual
world to the in itself qua a Beyond is
as much a negating as a positing of that
actual world finite reality can
therefore properly speaking be taken
just as one needs the sensuous is
therefore now related positively to the
absolute as to the in itself and
sensuous reality is itself an intrinsic
being the absolute makes it Foster's and
cherishes it then again is it is related
to the absolute as an opposite as to its
own non being in this relationship it is
not anything in itself but exists only
for an other whereas in the proceeding
shape of consciousness the notions of
the antithesis were determined as good
and bad in the case of pure insight on
the other hand they become the pure
abstractions of being in itself and
being for another
in paragraph 559 Hegel now is looking at
the relationship between these two first
moments of the truth of enlightenment
the truth that in lightness applying
that of absolute being understood as
something negative in a way even more
negative than the negative as we'll talk
about and then this entire realm of
sensuous being understood by the
singleness
of consciousness the individual and then
we're looking at the relationship
between these two moments and that's
what he's sketching out here as a third
moment of the truth of enlightenment and
this is actually a good place to say a
few remarks about you know what's going
on here how can a you know third moment
be the relationship between these other
two moments so this is very typical of
Hegel it's also Hegel thinks very
typical of consciousness the
relationship between these two which
will turn out to be one of antithesis as
he's saying that is itself something
that is being registered by
consciousness it is not something merely
reducible to the two terms of their
relationship rather it constitutes a
third aspect of it so that's worth
keeping in mind as we now move into this
discussion he tells us that this is the
relation of individual being to absolute
being it's sort of the relation between
the first two moments in sight he says
insight co-op your insight of what is
identical or unrestricted he says goes
beyond what is not identical so insight
you know you might say is actually in a
certain way on both sides of this divide
and yet the insight that we're talking
about is not the insight that say the
absolute being would possess at this
time the absolute being is really being
treated as an object for consciousness
much the same way that insight diagnosed
faith as treating absolute being as
something that doesn't have its own
agency right it will towards the end of
this passage though so insight is is
happening you could say over here on
this side right but it's going forth and
grasping what is available on this side
so Hegel goes on and he says insight qua
peer inside of what is identical or not
restricted goes beyond this beyond
finite reality now notice the next thing
he says beyond itself is mere other
nests insights as Hegel is constructing
it here is in a way self surpassing but
self surpassing towards something
something that is also at the same time
not as something not merely as something
not a subject of predicates because as
we saw this is a vacuum or as he's
calling it at this point avoid right
it's an emptiness and yet it has
absolute reality so he goes on and says
the beyond of this other nasir for it
relates the sensuous reality where does
the sensuous reality exists within the
void within the void that makes space
for it those of you who are well-versed
in continental philosophy and reading
this section you may actually have been
a little bit surprised you might have
said this actually sounds quite a bit
like some later thinkers for example
like heidegger's famous essay is going
for a theme that he's going to treat
over and over again
what is metaphysics and the nothing but
here it's absolute being it's not it's
not pure nothing and of course you know
where is Heidegger getting some of these
ideas
that he has he tells you right off the
bat he thinks Hegel is a very important
thinker in the history of philosophy
just didn't grasp everything that needed
to be grasped about say finitude or
history or the nature of spirit but
there is a similar dynamic going on here
and Hegel is not setting this out for
himself
he's attributing this to the movement of
enlightenment and its emphasis on the
sensuous the empirical and then whatever
it is that is supposed to go beyond it
so he goes on and he says for the beyond
of this other Ness it has the void right
to which therefore it relates the
sensuous reality in the determination of
this relation both of the sides do not
enter his content one of them is the
void there's no content in the void and
it is only through the other it is only
through what's on this side the things
of the world which are all sensuously
accessible to consciousness so he says
the sensuous reality that a content is
present that makes it possible for there
to be a void so there's not a void pre
things again it sounded kind of like
Heidegger isn't it so he says the form
of the relation the the determination of
which the side of the in itself
contributes can be a matter of choice we
can go and emphasize either side so this
means that insight or a consciousness as
pure insight actually has quite a bit of
freedom here it has a certain kind of
play going on that Hegel is going to
sketch out for us as a good
phenomenologist so he goes ahead and he
says the form is something intrinsically
negative therefore self opposed being as
well as nothing the in itself as well as
its opposite or even all these different
you know opposition's or what is the
same thing the relation of the actual
world the world of sensuous empirical
realities and our place among them
sensing them
operating upon them all of that is the
relation of the actual world to the in
itself qua a beyond and he said it's
just as much in the gating as a positing
of that actual world now what's he
talking about there so we do have a
positing they saying this is here the
actual world objects chalkboards pieces
of chalk myself the camera you we're all
objects within the world but we can also
negate them we can look at them as you
might say they're lack their relation of
not being what the absolute being is in
this case avoid so he says this can be a
negating of the actual world finite
reality here's the the kicker to this
and this is gonna be very important for
the next passage finite reality can
therefore be taken just as one needs
it's not so that we have a completely
true vision of the world for a purely
speculative purpose that we figure out
our metaphysics Hegel doesn't think that
that happens really for anybody
everybody's motivated by something to
know right we can decide what we're
going to make of this again this is
Hegel not speaking for himself but
pointing out what is going on in the
Enlightenment and its attitude towards
philosophy and consciousness and reality
so he says the sensuous now is related
positively to the absolute as to the in
itself and sensuous reality is itself an
intrinsic being and in itself right the
absolute makes it Foster's and cherishes
it that's one way of looking at it the
absolute allows the ten thousand things
to exist some people will catch that
reference all right then again it is
related he says to the absolute as an
opposite as to its own now
being the absolute you might say
threatens it says you're not what you
claim to be you're not truly sensuous
being because sensuous being doesn't
even really have being as such he says
in this relationship it is not anything
in itself but exists only for another
now Hegel is gonna draw a conclusion
here he says in the prevailing shapes of
consciousness the notions the the
concepts of the antithesis were
determined as good and bad right think
back to earlier parts of the culture
section here
what are they being determined as being
in itself being for another each of
these can be being in itself and the
other be being for another what is
deciding it inside that's what Hegel is
not saying here but what we have to
understand as determinative it is the
insight of the individual in the
Enlightenment who's taking a stance on
this so how is that going to be
determined then well we have to look at
the next passages
both ways of viewing the positive and
the negative relations of the finite to
the in itself are however in fact
equally necessary and everything is thus
as much something in itself as it is for
another in other words everything is
useful everything is at the mercy of
everything else
now let's itself be used by others and
is for them and now so to speak stands
again on its hind legs is standoffish
towards the other is for itself and uses
the other in its turn from this we see
what is the essence and what is the
place of man regarded as a thing that is
conscious of this relation as he
immediately is as a natural
consciousness per se man is good as an
individual he is absolute and all else
exists for him and moreover since the
moments have for him qua
self-consciously animal the significance
of universality everything exists for
his pleasure and delight and as one who
has come from the hand of God he walks
the earth as in a garden planted for him
he must also have plucked the fruit of
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil
he possesses in this an advantage which
distinguishes him from all other
creatures for it happens that his
intrinsically good nature is also so
constituted that an excessive pleasure
does it harm or rather his individuality
has also its Beyond within it can go
beyond beyond itself and destroy itself
to counter this reason is for him a
useful instrument for keeping this
excess within bounds or rather for
preserving himself when he overstepped
his limit for this is the power of
consciousness enjoyment on the part of
the conscious intrinsically a universal
being must not itself be something
determinate as regards variety and
duration but universal measure or
proportion has therefore the function of
preserve preventing pleasure in its
variety and duration from being cut
short that is the function of measure is
immoderation just as everything is
useful to man so man is useful too and
his vocation is to make himself a member
of the group of use for the common good
and serviceable for all the extent to
which he looks after his own interest
must also be matched by the extent to
which he serves others
so far as he serves others so far is he
taking care of himself one hand washes
the other
but wherever he finds himself there he
is in his right place he makes use of
others and as himself made use of
paragraph 560 is going to appear I think
to many readers as quite a departure
because we're now moving into the realm
of the practical or you might say the
ethical and the social very quickly away
from three paragraphs setting out in
very abstract metaphysical terms what
the truth of the Enlightenment is but
this is this is actually the culmination
for Hegel of that understanding of the
truth of enlightenment and it has to do
with what we just saw in the previous
paragraph you know we can look at the
things of the world and the the void or
the absolute in two different ways we
can choose which is going to be in
itself which is gonna be for itself and
we're the ones doing that choosing and
insight is involved in that so it's
insights taking out a position on itself
here Hegel talks about the useful the
newts think right or Knutson use of
something and he tells us that whatever
way we look at it we are concerned with
the useful at this point he says both
ways of viewing the positive and the
negative relations of the finite to the
in itself are equally necessary and
everything is thus just as much
something in itself as it is for another
everything is just as much in itself as
it is for another so let's think about
what the everything is there right we've
got the absolute the absolute is in
itself but it's also the absolute for
another the other of consciousness the
thing piece of chalk is in itself but it
is also for me not just for me in the
way that I'm looking at it and I'm
contemplating it I used it on this
chalkboard to do something it's also for
you in a certain way isn't it Hegel
doesn't go into that but that's
something that we could in fact explore
and then there's me
that me is something else that is in
itself I have being but I'm also for
another and I also am for myself so
notice that consciousness the human
being has a sort of prioritized position
in this case he depicts this by saying
everything is at the mercy of everything
else
now let's itself be used by others and
is for them part of being useful is
being useful for another right there is
no usefulness in and of itself
usefulness is because something else can
make use of it so he says and then now
so to speak stands on its hind legs is
standoffish towards the other and is for
itself and then uses the other in its
own turn so we really have you know like
we don't think about the self and other
we have the self in itself and we have
the other in itself to people and each
of them also has this relation to the
other of using them of making the other
or cajoling the other or allowing the
other to be for another for me for the
self and each of us can do that to the
other notice that there is a connection
here Hegel says between that standoffish
Ness and retreating into itself and then
saying AHA now I'm going to use you as
well I think that's an important point
there so he says from this we see what
is the essence and what is the place of
man the human being regarded as a thing
that is conscious of this relation as I
remarked a little bit earlier the human
being is a thing is a sensuous reality
but is one that is conscious of being
such maybe not in an explicit way but is
made conscious of that status if I hold
somebody responsible for the way in
which they arranged the room or write
things on the track board I am no longer
treating them as a mere machine
or as simply an animal let alone a--
just a pure thing I'm treating them as
something that has consciousness as
agency can be held of standards I am
also using them in that process so what
is the relationship of the human being
to the self and to the rest of the the
universe Hegel tells us as a person
immediately is as the natural
consciousness per se the human being is
good as an individual the the human
being is absolute and all else exists
for him this is egoism this is the sort
of unbridled egoism that we will see
later people in the wake of Hegel if not
necessarily Haig aliens stake out as the
ends of it right
so he says moreover since the moments
have for him as quash self-conscious
animal the significance of universality
everything exists for his pleasure he
talks about the you know the garden this
sort of idyllic existence everything is
out there for me whether it be candy for
me to consume and you know like is sweet
or beer for me to drink or trains for me
to hop on and ride around in the
landscape for me to look at the rain to
get me you know wet and and cool my
thirst the bodies of others for me to
take my pleasure in whether through eye
or hand or other organs right and we can
go on and on and on right I don't have
to multiply examples fireworks are there
for me to shoot off and enjoy so this is
a sort of natural existence that that
focuses on satisfaction he says he walks
the earth as in a garden planted for him
he says he must also have plucked the
fruit of the tree of knowledge of good
and evil so he's referring back to the
Eden story right he says he possesses in
this an advantage which distinguishes
him from all other creatures and here
Hegel goes through a line of practical
reasoning and this is one you know again
remember
this is about the enlightenment this is
typical of thinking about the
Enlightenment the Enlightenment is
saying listen all those priests telling
you don't enjoy your pleasures they're
full of it there they're enjoying their
pleasures in the end you know behind
closed doors to begin with and they just
don't want you to have a good time but
don't have too good of a good time why
not well you might get VD or you might
drink so much that you fall down the
stairs
or you might destroy your liver or and
we can go on and out of that right so
Hegel says we we have rationality reason
is something that we also use we use the
world we use reason to use the world in
a better way says to counter this reason
is for the human being a useful
instrument another thing that we have
for what preserving our self when we
overstep our limits this is the power of
consciousness Hegel says enjoyment must
not be itself be something determinate
as regards variety and duration but
Universal so what does measure or
proportion then do it has the function
of preventing pleasure in its variety
and duration from being cut short why
should you rationally pursue pleasure
well so you can have more of it right so
if you let's let's imagine some some
really kind of simple things I like beer
I like bitter beer you know actually I
like all sorts I like you know plenty of
things that aren't particularly bitter I
have a wide range of tastes I can't
drink beer all day long you know because
if I did well I would drink and then be
tired and go to sleep and wake up and be
hungover and drink some more and never
get anything done just live in kind of a
haze my entire life where after a while
I would you know really not register
much more than the intoxication and then
the bitter and somewhat sweet taste of
the beer and that's not much of a life
now is it right I would have to forgo
other pleasures you know if I all I did
was sit around and drink beer I'm an
beer was provided to me as much as I
want I I won some sort of contest and a
local brewery says all right dr. Sadler
is going to be the official you know
beer person and we'll just have a window
we can look in his apartment and watch
him drinking beer all day and see what
he does
I mean for the audience eventually they
would see me turn into a brute you know
laying around in my pajamas beer bottles
all over the place ordering pizzas you
know doing the sort of activities that
you can do in your drunk need to be
watching TV and maybe playing some video
games and occasionally getting up and
falling down and things along those
lines again not much of a life now is it
so he says the function of measure is
actually in moderation you you engage in
a certain amount of measure so that you
can have more it's to maximize your
pleasures now he then switches to
talking about the social world and he
says just as everything is useful to man
man is useful to man as well and our
vocation they says is to make yourself a
member of the group of use for the
common good and serviceable to all you
know we what do we tell kids you need to
learn something learn a profession you
know now don't read that Greek mythology
nobody's gonna pay you to do that go
learn how to weld go learn how to juggle
numbers become an accountant take the
business degree don't do the humanities
degree nobody's gonna pay you for that
why aren't they gonna pay you for that
because it's not useful to them as it
turns out you know we find all sorts of
situations where studying philosophy
history English those things turn out to
be useful now like when you have a
crisis or you got to make a difficult
decision or figure out why you're doing
accounting in the first place but too
many people in society you know we
arrange things in such a way as we're
supposed to have a vocation in to serve
society we're supposed to be serving the
other and the other is us we are serving
those like us in the process so he says
in so the extent to which he looks after
his own interests must also be matched
by the extent to which he serves others
so far as he serves others so far as he
taking care of himself Hegel says one
hand washes the other now notice how he
concludes this wherever he finds himself
there he's in the right place he makes
use of others and by others he has made
use of there's a kind of arbitrariness
to this isn't there there's no real
necessity for why things are the way
they are why are you a taxicab driver
mad you tap in that way why are you a
professor that just happened that way
now that is not going to provide a lot
of intelligibility so that's not going
to be the end of the story but notice
what Hegel has done here is sketched out
this entire realm of the useful and how
it fits in with consciousness
you